quisiera comenzar con una sencilla
pregunta y es si pensáis que esta imagen
pertenece a un bosque
quizás alguno haya visto esta imagen
alguna vez
efectivamente eso que parece un sombrero
puede acabar siendo una boa devorando un
elefante
y es que a veces eso que parece un
bosque pues sencillamente no lo es
y así el principito nos lleva a nuestra
infancia para hablar de cosas muy serias
muy reales y muy de mayores hoy vamos a
hablar de nuestros bosques hoy vamos a
intentar serpost porque antes ya fuimos
bosque y porque no nos queda más remedio
si queremos sobrevivir al futuro que
aprender de nuestros bosques
el bosque es ese lugar mágico que todo
el mundo alguna vez ha querido recorrer
ha querido dejarse impregnar por su
magia por su frondosidad por sus
dulces aromas y sus suaves melodías
un sueño alejado de la realidad y es que
volviendo un poco a mi infancia recuerdo
que solía subir a los cerros que había
cerca de el lugar donde vivía y que me
ofrecían una imagen de un valle conocido
de madrid que es el valle del jarama
por desgracia la imagen que yo veía en
mi infancia precisamente no era tan
idílica ni estaba cubierta de bosques en
su lugar podíamos ver
excavadoras y camiones cargados de grava
que iban destruyendo toda la naturaleza
que allí se encontraba
y además la correspondía mos devolviendo
devolviéndole todo lo que podéis ver
todos estos residuos que por desgracia
se extendían a lo largo y ancho de todo
el valle era un sueño aparentemente
inalcanzable para un simple niño de
aquella época y es que el valle del
jarama prácticamente desde que llegó el
ser humano hace aproximadamente unos
diez mil ocho mil años antes de la
llegada del ser humano estaba cubierto
por densos bosques bosques en él
podríamos ver un río jarama limpio
transparente y de aguas cristalinas
y sin embargo hace 40 años
en mi infancia lo que encontrábamos era
auténtica desolación no quedaba apenas
un árbol el río estaba contaminado y la
vega estaba ocupada por esas máquinas
que iban destruyendo todo por desgracia
esta situación no solamente se está
dando
en el valle del jarama aquí al lado de
madrid se está dando por todos los
rincones del planeta no nos tenemos que
ir muy lejos en el tiempo para comprobar
lo que ha pasado este mismo año pasado
como las llamas devoraban millones de
hectáreas de bosques por todo el planeta
en lugares tan distantes como australia
como la cuenca amazónica o siberia
y esto nos lleva
a una reflexión todos pensamos que
quizás el culpable de todo esto que está
pasando de esta gran crisis ambiental a
la que nos enfrentamos sea el ser humano
pero yo diría un poco más allá
quizás el problema no es el ser humano
sino más bien el desconocimiento humano
primero deberíamos preguntarnos qué es
un bosque
un bosque es simplemente un conjunto de
árboles que hay en el territorio o es
algo mucho más complejo y algo mucho más
rico es más importante el bosque es el
gran organismo vivo que lleva
funcionando de forma perfecta millones
de años en el planeta un bosque son aves
mamíferos anfibios insectos agua suelo
roca musgos líquenes sol viento
matorrales
árboles y deberíamos ser también ser
seres humanos el bosque así se configura
como la red social más importante
que podemos encontrar en el planeta
ahora precisamente que presumimos los
seres humanos de estar hiperconectados
nos hemos desconectado de esta que es la
red social más importante que hay en el
planeta es la red social que permite
nada más y nada menos que la vida
el bosque es un organismo vivo en
equilibrio y en constante evolución
es permite
que pueda acoger con el paso del tiempo
cada vez a más individuos y a más
especies distintas y no solamente eso
sino que además mejora ese territorio
con el paso del tiempo va mejorando ese
territorio incluso podemos ver bosques
donde no hay ni siquiera árboles a veces
allá en un territorio donde no vemos
árboles también hay un bosque hay un
bosque que está esperando a que nosotros
le dejemos stars salir desarrollarse
debemos paso para que pueda evolucionar
en esa medida
he dicho que efectivamente hay un
elemento que está impidiendo
precisamente su evolución y su armonía
que está destruyendo todos esos lazos
que llevan conviviendo de forma armónica
durante millones de años ese elemento se
llama el ser humano ha sido capaz de
destruir más del 60 por ciento de los
bosques del planeta en los últimos
tiempos simplemente un dato de la fao
entre el año 2000 y 2010 se destruían
una media de 13 millones de hectáreas
cada año en los últimos años todavía se
ha incrementado aún más ese ritmo de
destrucción tenemos aquí una imagen del
valle del jarama hace 70 años
prácticamente ya no quedaba ningún
bosque habíamos destruido la naturaleza
lejos de pensar y de reflexionar sobre
si estábamos haciendo bien o mal las
cosas nosotros los seres humanos se nos
ocurre decir como esto ya no vale para
nada vamos a cubrirlo con una hermosa
capa de ladrillo
y eso es lo que hemos hecho hoy con ese
valle del jarama por lo menos en gran
parte del mismo y así tenemos esa
maravillosa imagen hoy en día
y es que los bosques nos molestan para
todo y además encontramos excusas para
decir que nos molestan los bosques
decimos que nos molestan los bosque de
ribera cuantas veces no hemos oído que
hay que limpiar las orillas de nuestros
ríos porque son las que provocan las
inundaciones nada más lejos de eso los
bosques precisamente lo que hacen es
prevenir las avenidas y evitar la
erosión de nuestros ríos cuántas veces
hemos seguido que hay que limpiar los
bosques porque son los que provocan los
incendios y además hemos encontrado una
palabra mágica que se llama maleza
llamamos maleza al futuro de nuestros
bosques a los elementos que componen el
bosque a los árboles que están empezando
a crecer a las plantas a los arbustos en
donde se alimentan los animales que
permiten que el bosque tenga vida
están en definitiva los bosques para
crecer ilimitadamente en un modelo que
nos hemos inventado los seres humanos
que es totalmente lineal
cogemos todo lo que hay en el planeta
más bien arrasamos con todo lo que hay
en el planeta y al cambio le devolvemos
al planeta al que residuos y
contaminación
del bosque deberíamos aprender a doblar
esa línea recta y hacerla totalmente
circular hacerla totalmente sostenible
porque en el bosque se recicla
completamente todo como es posible que
nosotros que somos los seres más
inteligentes eso decimos los seres más
inteligentes del planeta no queramos
formar parte de esta que es la red
social más importante que tenemos la red
social como decía que permite la vida
esa es la reflexión que me hacía hace
unos años simplemente decidí bajar desde
el cerro y a partir de ahí empecé a
contactar con asociaciones colectivos
instituciones y personas sobre todo con
personas y nos pusimos en marcha antes
de que el avance de la ciudad no dejara
opción para la recuperación de este
valle que es el valle más importante que
tenemos en madrid el valle del jarama
y así empezamos a actuar como si
fuéramos parte del bosque cada uno
cumplimos una misión cada uno empezamos
a trabajar de forma complementada de
forma unida empezamos a limpiar la
cantidad de residuos que se encuentran
por todos los rincones de este valle
empezamos a dialogar también con el
bosque empezamos a ver cómo los animales
que hay en el bosque son piezas
fundamentales para que se puedan
dispersar las semillas y empezamos a
cuidar de esos animales también que son
pieza clave por supuesto cogimos
semillas también de los árboles arbustos
plantas y empezamos a plantar los en
nuestro vivero para poder también
plantar árboles no queremos batir ningún
récord no queremos aparecer en los
titulares de los periódicos hemos
plantado un millón cien millones
doscientos no se trata de plantar muchos
árboles se trata simplemente de observar
y actuar como si fuéramos el bosque el
bosque es mucho más que plantar árboles
y también no nos olvidamos de ellos
ellos son los que van a vivir en este
valle van a vivir en este planeta dentro
de unos años y por eso lo primero que
estamos haciendo con ellos también es a
que salgan a aprender el lenguaje del
bosque a comunicarse con los bosques
y así aprenden cosas fundamentales como
el que un árbol que es un elemento muy
visible del bosque o el elemento con el
que identificamos a los bosques es capaz
de consumir aproximadamente unas 10
toneladas de dióxido de carbono que es
el equivalente al que pueden emitir 10
vehículos a lo largo de un año o que se
puede o que puede producir 10 toneladas
de oxígeno qué es lo que necesita una
persona para vivir para respirar también
a lo largo de un año incluso que allí
donde hay árboles podemos reducir
aproximadamente unos 5 grados la
temperatura donde se encuentran que
pueden movilizar unos 100 litros de agua
desde el suelo hasta la atmósfera
convirtiéndose precisamente en los
mejores defensores de las nefastas
consecuencias del cambio climático son
los auténticos climatizadores naturales
ahora que no podemos vivir sin un aire
acondicionado
así estamos empezando a cambiar el
lenguaje nuestra forma de comunicarnos
cambiamos la palabra destrucción por la
de recuperación cooperación conservación
es
algo fundamental si queremos devolverle
la vida al valle del jarama vida que
poco a poco se va viendo resurgir
estamos viendo como resurgen ya los
bosques por distintos lugares del río
jarama a pesar de que la ciudad de
madrid sigue acercándose sigue llamando
a la puerta del valle asoma sobre sus
colinas
estamos aprendiendo en definitiva de los
bosques para no olvidarnos de dónde
venimos el futuro de la humanidad
depende precisamente de ese conocimiento
de cómo funciona la naturaleza de
nuestro amor hacia la naturaleza en el
valle del jarama vivimos aproximadamente
medio millón de personas
seremos una amenaza o una oportunidad en
función de lo que hagamos a partir de
ahora
nuestro gran reto es salvar y conservar
a este que es el valle más importante
que hay en madrid si todas las personas
que vivimos en el planeta actuamos desde
la de la misma manera en el lugar donde
vivimos os puedo asegurar que vamos a
salvar al planeta y así cuando veamos
una imagen como la del sombrero el
sombrero del principito ya sabremos
todos mirad el planeta
de otra manera podremos ver más allá
podremos dejarnos contagiar de la magia
del bosque recordaremos además una frase
de esta obra maravillosa que es lo
esencial es invisible a los ojos y así
solo entenderemos el bosque como una
pieza fundamental de nuestras vidas si
podremos salvarlo y con ello también
salvaremos a una especie que nunca hubo
de olvidar de dónde viene esa especie es
la nuestra la especie humana muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]